précède rené-corail dansante a dit
bonjour madame rené corail vous êtes
membre du comité départemental du modem
martinique parti centriste qui a qui a
décidé de prendre ses distances avec le
grand semblait pumba payant chance
quelles sont les raisons de ce désamour
de ce divorce
nous parlerons pas la défense nous
dirons simplement que nous avions eu ni
effectivement une alliance lors des
élections parce que nous prenons le
rassemblement au modem si notre
leitmotiv nous avions nous partagions
sur la profession le programme certaines
idées communes maintenant il s'avère que
nous ne sommes plus dans cette même
dynamique donc nous préférons c'est vous
qui avez changé nous c'est vous qui avez
décidé que des choses se passaient pas
comme vous le vouliez au moment de l'
alliance ge et termine par rapport aux
programmes que nous avions présenté aux
élections
nous suivions sur certains points une
même dynamique il s'est avéré que après
les élections ce n'était plus le cas
nous avons pris nos responsabilités et
nous sommes sortis de cette alliance est
ce qui a changé selon vous je ne pourrai
l'expliqué de leur point de vue nous
simplement ce que nous avons noté c'est
que les idées qui étaient annoncés aux
dépens les réunions qui devaient avoir
lieu de discussion pour un pot permettre
l'évolution du peuple martiniquais
l'élévation de la martinique ces
discussions ces réunions n'ont pas eu
lieu
donc nous avons préféré prendre nos
distances les hommes les femmes du modem
n'ont pas de représentant 5 du grand
ensemble et papillon chance aux
commandes à la ctm les hommes qui sont
aux commandes vous ont déçu les
pratiques non nous ne parlerons pas de
déception il y avait des choix à faire
ces choix a été fait ces choix étaient
discutés
maintenant nous nous attendions d'avoir
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure de
la discussion de la communication sur
les points à mettre en avant sur les
axes à travailler ça n'a pas été fait
donc voilà les raisons qui nous ont
poussés nous à nous écarter
que pensez vous de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui notamment ce débat autour
des finances le déficit ces conclusions
de la chambre régionale des comptes ont
trouvé que cela fait
que cela fait désordre trouvé que cela
fait désordre je n'emploierai pas ce mot
je dirai simplement que le premier
trimestre a été passé à nous à nous
faire état d'une situation alarmante
d'une situation financière désastreuse
et il a fallu claque ou des comptes
viennent rétablir l'ordre en publiant
deux chiffres et encore en publiant des
chiffres qui montrent que la situation
n'est pas ce qu'elle ait dit ce qui est
dit ce qui est annoncé ce qui expose est
donc ajoute à la confusion au discrédit
de la chose afrique
j'espère simplement que face à ces
chiffres
face à cette publication que tout un
chacun réfléchira et prendra conscience
de ce qui existe qui est fait max
orville le président du de votre
mouvement le modem estime elodie dernier
cédant dans france antilles que la
démocratie ne fonctionnait pas au sein
de la collectivité de des territoriales
de martinique expliqué nous cela nous
avons le sentiment que tous les pouvoirs
enfin toutes les prises de décisions
sont réunis dans une seule main mais
qu'est donc uniquement les mains de
l'exécutif
donc nous ne pouvons pas parler de
démocratie en ce sens vous pensez que
claude lise le président de l'assemblée
et prouesses berliet face alfred
marie-jeanne ce que voulait dire je ne
crois pas avoir dit cela
nous avons simplement dit que nous avons
le sentiment qu'il n'y a qu'un seul
centre de décision qu'il n'y a pas de
vraie séparation des pouvoirs et qu'il
n'y a pas de vraie discussion autour des
décisions
alors maintenant que le modem a pris ses
distances maintenant qu'elle a tiré ses
conclusions maintenant qu'elle a pris
ses responsabilités
vous allez faire quoi gars de déchéance
bientôt notamment les législatives
l'important pour vous l'urgence est qu
au niveau du modem on rappelle que vous
êtes autour d'eux
200 membres ici en martinique oui
effectivement nous sommes en un peu plus
de 200 membres ajouts et depuis depuis
notre prise de position nous recevons
beaucoup d'appels beaucoup de messages
nous félicitons d'ailleurs de notre
prise de position c'est cette étape dans
le dos ça veut pas dire monteront-ils
manifestants la déception vis-à-vis du
grand semblait de la 7e et de la
situation cela ne veut peut-être pas
dire grand chose
comment faire mais nous avons quand même
des messages la déception de côté et au
contraire de deux souhaits de
rassemblement dans notre plan comment
faire pour capitaliser tout cela nous
donnons aux martiniquais le temps de se
positionner nous leur laissons le choix
nous ne forçons bea selon jean ce de
situation non monsieur viol dont il n'y
a pas d'urgence de situation nous ne
travaillons pas dans l'urgence
nous travaillons dans le rassemblement
de la réflexion car comment faire
la recette nous nous continuons à
défendre notre programme à défendre nos
idées nous à continuer à oeuvrer pour le
rassemblement pour l'évolution du peuple
martiniquais
nous sommes au modem des personnes qui
avant nos activités qui ne vivons pas de
politique
donc nous a tourné le dos aux
républicains de tourner le dos aux
forces martiniquaises de progrès au mime
au parti communiste avec qui vous allez
parler rassemblement lui dis peut-être
lui dénient martinique par les
rassemblements avec lui des imans
tonique je pose la question qui sont
centristes comme vous pas plus que vous
pas moi ce que vous n'en a pas nous
n'avons pas encore fait et 1 il n'en est
pas à façonner pas à l'ordre du jour
nous n'avons pas tourné le dos aux
républicains nous avons tourné le dos à
une catégorie de républicains ce ne
seront jamais dit sur le bobo plusieurs
choses nous à nous n'avons jamais dit
que nous ne travaillerons plus avec
aucune équipe
nous disons simplement que nous
travaillons avec ceux qui oeuvrent
réellement pour le rassemblement par de
quel rassemblement parlez vous qu'est ce
que vous voulez dans ce rassemblement
qui voulaient autour de du modem avec le
modem en partenariat modèle des
personnes qui feront fi réellement de
projets qui ont de vraies perspectives
d'évolution pour le pays
pour le peuple des personnes qui ne vont
pas passer neuf mois à parler de ce que
faisait de ce qu'a fait de ce qu'a
produit l'ancienne mandature au lieu de
faire des propositions 9 pour avancer
nous avons besoin d'être d'esprit vif
d'esprit réel 4 qui les fait tous un
vrai besoin d'évoluer et d'évolution qui
vont faire de vraies propositions sur
lesquelles emploient avoir des
projections
non nous ne regardons pas dans le
rétroviseur on ne travaille pas dans la
rancune dans la haine ou dans la
déception on travaille dans le souhait
d'avancer dans le désir réel de
construire qu'est ce que vous aimeriez m
comme matériau de construction pour
cette martinique de demain de la
communication de l' échange de la vérité
delà de la clarté nous voulons être
comme on dit en clair dans tout ce que
nous annonçons nous sommes clairs notre
ce que nous allons nous assumons ce que
nous disons et nous parlons librement
nous n'allons pas nous ne travaillons
pas à dénigrer ni a commenté à défaire
ce qui a été fait en pour le plaisir de
faire le papa pour le plaisir mais
simplement pour critiquer nous nous
voulons juste avancé nous prenons notre
temps mais nous voulons avancer et vous
allez faire quoi pour les prochaines
législatives où vous envisagez déjà
d'envoyer des candidats nous dans nous
envisageons au modem martinique d'être
présent sur toutes les élections qui
auront lieu et qui auront a trait au
peuple martiniquais
après nous ne nous sommes pas
positionnés en convention le choix du
candidat sur si nous allions à quelqu'un
ou pas mais pour l'instant nous nous
souhaitant être présent sur toutes les
élections qui pourront être nécessaires
au peuple martiniquais
le modem qui demande le discours de la
vérité de la clarté merci d'abriter ce
matin avec nous que ce tel rené corail
rappelle que vous êtes membre du comité
départemental du modem martinique merci
d'avoir été avec nos bonnes journées
merci beaucoup